[Musique]
pour la semaine de relâche jeux vidéo
jeux de société jeux de rôle
pas moins de 300 activités dans quarante
cinq bibliothèques de montréal sont au
programme du festival montréal joue
samedi ce sera la nuit blanche de
montréal en lumière et l'hôtel de ville
se transforme en véritable terrain de
jeu pour les 6 ans et plus avec des jeux
vidéo un laboratoire de création et de
la musique
la grande bibliothèque fait aussi la
nuit blanche mais dans le noir à
l'espace jeunes des accessoires
phosphorescent donc être enfilé pour
être visible et danser et pour les plus
tranquilles
le reste de la semaine est consacrée à
la lecture de contes et à la projection
de films qu'il veut nullement par an
dans le monde
le musée mccord à une programmation
spécialement conçu pour les petits et
pouvant plaire aux grands aussi avec une
exposition de jouets de toutes les
époques
le musée nous remémorent des trésors
presque oublié et cartes d'exploration à
la main les petits partis à la
découverte du musée pour en apprendre
sur l'art et l'histoire sur scène place
aux marionnettes avec le festival de
casteliers 11 spectacles pour enfants et
adultes de compagnie dissipe des états
unis et de la france et pour son
inauguration la maison internationale
des arts de la marionnette présente un
spectacle gratuit ici à l'extérieur le
samedi 9 mars
non je ne doit plus être le seul à
connaître la formule de la potion
magique lé festival international du
film pour enfants de montréal reste un
incontournable après vingt deux ans
signer à dos 1re courts et longs
métrages les cinéma beaubien du parc et
du musée des beaux-arts offre une
centaine de films d'une trentaine de
pays
oui sa grande passion c'est la musique
classique et si votre adolescent ne veut
rien savoir de ce que je viens de vous
suggérer le centre fi propose une
expérience alliant le théâtre le cinéma
et la réalité virtuelle ses 13 ans et
plus sur ce amusez-vous caylar large
après tout si si julie jocelyne
boudreault phrase au canada montréal